I just want to give you some context as to where we are before we move forward.
We have seen examples of different narrative structures and
what effect they have on our overall visualization,
including both author-driven and reader-driven narratives.
And we've also seen what flexibility and power interactivity affords us
when creating a customized graphic that we want our readers to explore.
And we have seen how to add context to our World Cup visualization, but
in doing so, have learned that both a line plot and
a scatter plot may not be the best form to convey our data story.
In this lesson, we will further iterate on our graphic and
continue this process of sketching to arrive at our final visualization.
The first step in this process will be to add geographic context to
our visualization by plotting our data on a map.
And throughout, I'll show you how to enhance an author-driven narrative
by leveraging temporal effects through animation with D3.
And we will finish by creating the mouth of the martini glass structure by
allowing a reader to explore a graphic interactively, in addition to
being able to drill down and inspect data at a much more finer grain.